est-ce que c'est à votre connaissance
que plusieurs membres du conseil
d'administration
il ya des organisateurs politiques
libéraux qui ont grandement contribué à
leur installation conseil des ministres
à 6,60 cerveau je pourrais pas vous dire
je ne sais je ne saurais vous dire si le
conseil d'administration c'est clair que
là c'est peut-être que je devrais pas
dire ça mais d'aller sur le conseil
d'adminstration de la sic
ah c'est pas le plus prestigieux
moi j'irai jamais sur le conseil
d'admistration de là c'est pourquoi pas
s'est passé prestigieux sabords ça
pendant real but aly midi mais
m'intéresser aux édifices du
gouvernement
zéro intérêt ce jeudi sa coppola lui les
gens qui sont prêts à aller au conseil
d'administration de la csg juste la
difficulté dan dah pas bon là d'un sepa
sepa prestigieux
il lit vous sur le conseil
d'administration de la cei vous j'ai
aucune compétence pour faire fermer
oui mais ça vous intéresse vous tentait
pas de mettre déjà compétents la rue
taché est important il ya bien trop de
compétences ils meurent et personne n'a
compétents pour agir elle ils sont là
sinon non mais il voit là un gros
problème
ben c'est clair mais les jeux sont peu
intéressés à la sic mais ça vous
tenterait pas le régler le problème
on va faire un organisme qui fonctionne
calcul qui connaît la construction qui a
été dans la construction qui connaît la
location ecce terra des jeux qui sont
bons la de ne pas aller à québec à la
sic au japon une personne qui a dit
monique jamas est nommé la sic c'est
clair que vous semblez indiqué qu'il
était normal que je ne penche pas sur ça
sincèrement ça ne m'intéresse pas ça ne
m'intéressait pas patel j'aurais été
intéressé
- monique jérôme forget ça ne
m'intéressait pas la suite ne
m'intéressait pas